all right everybody thank you so much
for coming out my name is Keith and I'm
here from corporate to talk about our
office relationship policy was these two
they were the ones making whoopee oh
yeah dude I just want to say that I made
a mistake
and I fully support the ban on office
romance well actually there is no ban
believe it or not yours truly is in an
office romance this is Kim and we are in
a fun and professional relationship
isn't she the best look at that smile I
miss her so much
I've been on the road for a week doing
this presentation but I am flying home
tonight so Kate's keys to a successful
office relationship
number one is respect and respect not
just for your co lover but for your
coworker last one yep it sounds like we
struck a chord there let's dive deeper
into that okay would that be deeper into
your relationship with Kim Kim right
great idea let's use an example so Kim's
assistant Jamie came to us a year ago
because he was feeling uncomfortable
with setting up our dinner reservations
so we started handling it ourselves no
no no no don't worry because we were say
with me now respectful and now Kim's
professional relationship with Jamie is
stronger than ever I promise you that so
moving on to number 2 of Keith's keys
Keith I know what you guys are gonna say
and it's an intentional Type O great
typo Keith question yeah what role does
communication have in say an office
breakup well I've never been part of a
failed office relationship so I
hypothetically hypothetically well I'd
be devastated I would have trouble
finding light in this dark dark world
but luckily that will never happen to me
oh my god miraculous isn't she she is my
everything only second to
loafie here no don't worry I'm gonna
continue the presentation right after I
get an eyeful of my best friend in the
entire world uh Kaylin I still love you
I knew it see Kate's keys can lead to a
successful office relationship great job
Keith mission accomplished
I'll see you out actually I have dozens
more Keith keys well no need because you
were able to repair Callen and Anna's
disgusting mistake of a relationship so
let's give Keith a round of applause
thank you so much blow it up you can
along huh let's just wait it out you can
move into my place no it's a big fan
you